any artists any person but especially
artists have to know their y-you have to
know why you're showing up in the first
place the worst thing in business in
life is being around people who don't
believe the same things you do why why
do you want to be successful rise and
shine it's an espresso time what's up
belief nation it's Evan I believe in you
and this channel is designed to be a
part of your daily success routine so
let's start your day off right together
grab your copy and sip on today's
message express your beliefs over you
simon Sinek also if you want to know
what simon Sinek and others have to say
about building unstoppable confidence
check out my 2:54 confident series where
every day for the next 254 days i will
send you a morning video for free to
help you build your confidence the link
to join is in the description below you
get the benefit of hearing what
everybody else has to think before you
render your opinion it's like a hammer
you can use it broadly or narrowly you
can build a table you can build a house
it's the same tool I went to see a play
with a friend of mine who is an actor
and the play was awful I mean a train
wreck the script was awful the directing
was awful I mean it was an absolute
train wreck
so the question does now the question
you asked was about collaboration right
should any of those actors have taken
the part now of course if you're gonna
take a part because you need an extra
cash a little extra cash or you want to
get a little extra practice then you
have to do so I think knowing I'm doing
this for the money or I'm doing this
just to keep keep my skills sharp but
I'm under no illusion that this is
something that I connect with but I'm
gonna do the best that I can and then
don't lie to yourself you know the other
problem is don't do that too often
because that'll just destroy any passion
that you have for your medium right and
I think and we've talked about this
which is which is any artist any person
but especially
have to know there why you have to know
why you're showing up in the first place
and you have to be able to talk about it
because if you talk about it things
happen people go I like you right now
you may not get the part but you're more
likely to find people who want to work
with you even if you're not the most
talented one who auditioned this is my
career by the way right when I learned
to talk about what I believed I didn't
talk about the things I've done I didn't
talk about the parts I've had or the
shows I've been in or who trained me
where the schools I went to resume
resume resume I started I learned to
talk about what I believed and some
people thought it was cheesy they didn't
call me back good and some people went
that's great and I was not the most
talented not the most experienced not
the best at my field but because they
stood for or believed in what I stood
for they wanted to work with me they
would rather work with someone who
understood them who got them more than
somebody who would just take orders and
do exactly what they wanted regardless
of facility when you lead with what you
believe you bring the right people into
your life you attract them like a magnet
like bees to honey you're different you
stand out does have reason to go and be
with you to work with you to date you to
marry you to be with you because you
believe the same things most people
don't do that
most people just look for the talent
he'll just look for the skills they
don't care about the beliefs and then
they end up struggling the worst thing
in business in life is being around
people who don't believe the same things
you do think about your own experiences
like you love people that you've been
forced to work with who don't have the
same beliefs as you do and how terrible
that is if you do not work with people
if you are not surrounded by people who
have a similar belief system as you you
will hate your life and never accomplish
anything great it sucks and so it's not
their fault though that their crappy
people they're not crappy people they
just believe different things in you and
it's up to you to lead with your belief
so that you start bringing the right
people to you okay so let's talk about
how
actually do that how do you express your
beliefs how do you lead with your
beliefs well step one is figuring out
what are your beliefs go through the one
word exercise that's what it is it's
figuring out your most important core
value your biggest core belief and
you'll eat with that if you don't know
what your core value is there's no way
to lead with it so your first job is to
figure out what that is and what it
means to you whether you use your
one-word process or there's another one
that works for you you have to identify
what your most important core belief is
step two is you let your market and do
the heavy lifting in any piece of
content that you're putting that whether
it's a YouTube video whether it's a job
ad any brochure that you're putting up
your website your social media you let
your marketing do the heavy lifting for
you and so you know that I'm all about
belief it's impossible to avoid I'll eat
with it all the time it's in every video
it's in every conversation if you love
believed and it's gonna be a magnet if
you want more belief in your life I am
the I'm the best guy in the world to go
to if you hate believe you hate the
messaging awesome
you'll never subscribe to my channel
will never likely end up working
together will repel each other and
that's great and that's exactly the
point you want to repel the people who
do not share the same belief system as
you and attract the ones who do let me
give you a quick example when I'm hiring
somebody when I hire somebody I put in a
job at the very first paragraph when I
hire somebody want to put another job ad
the title will be something like I'm
looking for a video editor who believes
in entrepreneurs hashtag believes in
entrepreneurs okay already it's
different it's unique it's a little wild
and crazy first paragraph will be only
about the mission what we're all about
what we believe in why aren't yours are
gonna save the world all of that that's
built in it's the very first paragraph
I'm not getting to video editing or any
of the details of the Job Description
yet why because I want people to either
love what I'm all about or hate it the
people who look at that and there will
be many people will look at that job
title and the first paragraph would say
this is the stupidest job ad I've ever
seen I'm just a video editor just one of
her edit videos I don't want to go
through all this amazing they won't
apply like you let your marketing do the
heavy lifting they'll never even get to
you because they've self selected out
and they can go find another job that's
better suited for them awesome some
people go will love it they'll look at
that job ad and say holy cow
finally this is this is what I've been
waiting for this is the ideal company
for me where has this company been I
hate these jobs I've been working that
finally I want to go work for this
company and they'll work even harder to
impress you because they believe the
same things that you believe and it's
gonna be a great working fit for you
guys together
I look at Christina who's been doing my
video editing for I don't know how many
years many years and she wanted to put
believe on her arm she wanted to get a
tattoo of belief before ever meeting me
and when she saw the job ad she worked
the hardest of anybody that applied for
the job we had a lot of people who
wanted to apply to be my video editor
she was one of them and she worked the
hardest and gave the most options and
the most details and was the nicest
person to work with of everybody who
went through the trial process because
she believed in what I was doing because
she believed the same things I believed
she proved herself and I hired her and
we've been working together for years
and so the reason why you might have a
crappy business the reason why you might
have a crappy life is because the people
around you are not believing the same
thing that you believe and it's your
fault you have not figured out what your
one word core belief is and you have not
expressed that and I get it it's scary
there's fear ridicule this fear of
rejection so you're about that that's
silly who are you to be that person who
are you to believe in this thing that's
crazy and because you're afraid to do it
because you're afraid to share it
because you're afraid of the rejection
of people who are small-minded they
don't believe the same things you do
then you never actually get to build the
business that you could then you never
actually get to have the people in your
life that you should and so the quality
of your life the success of your
business will be in direct proportion to
how much the people around you believe
the same things you believe and if you
don't find it for yourself and you don't
express it and share it you will never
build the business you could you never
be happy in your relationships now I've
got a really special bonus clip that I
think you're going to enjoy but before
that question today I want to know what
is your one-word core belief let me know
put in the comments below
everybody's putting out the best photo
from their vacation ever
everybody's putting out the most
exciting night of their lives people are
actually now doing things in real life
just for the photo to put on Instagram
and this is very important to understand
because we as humans are wired often to
envy and be jealous and curious and
dwell on not being on that boat and what
that leads to is short-term behavior
everybody's looking to make a quick
dollar so that they can go on that yacht
or go to Ibiza or buy that car or that
bag or that sneaker and this is 100
percent the poison that is in the system
and so for me I want to know why why do
you want to be successful for me I
didn't even really necessarily want to
be successful I just couldn't breathe
if I wasn't selling something or
building a business it's all I knew
there was nothing else it was why I was
such a bad student
I couldn't even appease the hour I
needed to be a decent student a day
because I needed every minute selling
baseball cards or wine or whatever I was
up to at that point in my life there was
no choice and so that's what I wish on
everybody else I wish that you wake up
every morning and have no choice that
what you do is how you breathe raise
your standard Apple at the core its core
values is that passion
not one drop of myself work depends on
your it's something serene if you want
more Simon Simon check out the top ten
rules video I made on him the link is
right there next to me I think you'll
enjoy it continue to believe and I'll
see you there some people see the thing
that they want and some people see the
thing that prevents them from getting
the thing that they want